una carrera contra la viruela del mono
en nuevayork epicentro de los casos en
los eeuu las vacunas para inmunizar
contra la enfermedad no dan abasto hasta
este 14 de julio se contabilizan al
menos unos 390 casos de un total
nacional de 1.470 mientras las
autoridades intentan gestionar las pocas
dosis existentes las citas para
vacunarse se agotan rápidamente
[Música]
también frustrados por la cantidad de
suministros que tenemos de esta vacuna
que no estamos haciendo todas las citas
a través del sitio web del público
porque estamos tratando de tener en
cuenta las necesidades de las personas
que podrían no tener internet benito
son varios los síntomas de este tipo de
padecimiento fiebre dolor de cabeza
garganta dolores musculares lesiones en
la piel los genitales o la boca entre
otros la viruela del mono desaparece por
sí sola pero su desarrollo puede ser muy
doloroso habitantes de nueva york' y
ciudadanos de paso creen que pudo
organizarse mejor el proceso de
distribución de las dosis
es frustrante en gran vida porque
especialmente con kobe uno pensaría que
tendría un proceso más estructurado para
la aplicación de las vacunas y realmente
no había nada en las autoridades de
salud neoyorquinas se disculparon a
principios de semana por el fallo de su
sitio web ante la alta demanda para
inmunizarse
según el centro para el control y
prevención de enfermedades cdc para las
jornadas por venir se espera un aumento
de los casos